how long have you been a man oh pretty  much my whole life anything surprising  ah the coldness inability to touch  anyone else and touch you in any real  way I mean just it for instance my dog  Diane just died she was my best friend  the dog's name was Miss Diane yeah it's  kind of odd name for a dog Dan he's  named after who Diane Sawyer I mean what  other news woman would you name a dog  after he couldn't wander you wouldn't  call it dog Barbara you could call the  dog Sawyer and I would have been cool  Sawyer Diane Diane the dogs dead right  no the dog is too okay I mean if she  were coming I wouldn't want her to come  cuz she'd be like a zombie right right  right and then we'd have to kill her  again for more awesome videos that teach  you how to be a man  subscribe to our YouTube channel and  follow us on Twitter